Speaker 1: Donald Trump gave an interview
yesterday and he again did this bizarre
N-word rant. This is his new bit. He knows
exactly who is audiences. And this was an
interview in which Donald Trump seemed very
confused, quite disoriented. Take a listen.
Speaker 2: If you look at Putin with his talk.
Speaker 1: Button.
Speaker 2: And if you look this is not talk, you
don't mentioned that thing, that thing that we
don't want to talk about. I say the N-word. Well,
it means the nuclear word. The N-word is the
nuclear word. And that is a threat like nobody's
had out there. I mean, he's talking about that
openly and it's being handled very badly.
Speaker 3: I agree with you.
Speaker 2: That shouldn't have.
Speaker 3: Happened. We are being.
Speaker 2: Hurt very badly from within.
Speaker 1: Trump knows exactly who his
audience is. He knows exactly how to find
people, the N-word, the N-word. And you might
remember that clip from his rally over the weekend
where Trump brought up the N-word and he goes,
You know what that is? And then the crowd thinks
they know which N-word he's talking about. And
then Trump has to pacify them and go, No, no, no,
no, no, no, no. I mean nuclear. I mean nuclear or
nucular, as some like to say. Donald Trump seems
to think that Putin is winning in Ukraine despite
a protracted stalemate at best for Russia.
Speaker 3: Now, Mr. President, if you get
reelected, let's just say hypothetically here,
you get back in. What would you do to broker peace
right away? Because I don't hear anybody from
the European Union and definitely in the Biden
regime trying to convince these two Zelensky
and Putin to get to the table and do what's
right for the innocent people dying, by the.
Speaker 1: Way, before Trump delivers his
foreign policy analysis. This is an omen. Trump
is increasingly relegated to being interviewed
on Newsmax and oan Fox had him last week to
try to help him out. But he is increasingly
not welcome on mainstream networks.
Speaker 3: In the middle, which is
come to the peace bargaining table.
Nobody's willing to discuss that.
Speaker 2: Well, it would have been much
easier before it happened, but it did happen.
And that's where we are right now. The thing
you have to do is get the oil price down and
Russia will stop because Russia's getting at
$100 a barrel. Russia has never had. They've
never had wealth like this before. And despite
the war and the cost of the war and what the
war is doing to everybody and the killing,
the tremendous killing that's taking place.
If you get oil down to, you know, I had
it down to $40 a barrel. I had it down to
less than that. We had gasoline at one point.
Speaker 1: Remember, the collapse in the oil
market was because of COVID. Now Trump
is praising it like it's a good thing.
Speaker 2: And down to a dollar and $0.49.
Can you believe it? I remember now you look at
where it is. You look at where it is right now.
Everybody was buying very big cars and trucks.
They were driving trucks. They wanted not even
SUVs. Let's go buy a truck. But we had it down
to a level that nobody's seen in decades and
decades and decades. And it was a great thing.
This country was booming and then they shut it
off. But what you do is you have to get the oil
price down. You get the oil price down. The the
you get it down to 40, $50 a barrel. The war
will stop automatically. You don't even have
to talk to anybody would stop automatically.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, this entire framing is
completely absurd. Trump seems to think Putin is
actually winning in Ukraine, despite the reality
on the ground being dramatically different. But
you're not going to get push back on way, and
they're not they're certainly not going to push
back about that. Now, one interesting moment was
that, you know, Oann is one of the most weaponised
disinformation audiences that is out there and
right wing media. A.I.M. on Oann Trump stood by
the vaccines for COVID as well as Operation Warp
Speed, which I don't know that the audience here
is necessarily going to love. But remember, Trump
is desperate to have something to take credit for.
Speaker 2: As far as Operation Warp Speed. I mean,
I've been given great reviews on that by a lot
of people. We've done that. We did an incredible
job. You know what? We handed it back over after
a rigged election. We handed it back over. The
stock market was higher than it was prior to
COVID to the day before COVID came in. And by the
way, the stock market is higher than it is right
now. I don't know if anybody's noticed that.
Speaker 3: We've lost 7 trillion is Biden took
over. Yeah I was going to get to that economy
but I still got to get that background question
out. Mr. President, just because I get so
many viewers asking with the side effects,
where does Mr. Trump stand on that?
Speaker 1: The side effects guys,
the side effects, which are what,
again, just look like a little bit.
Speaker 3: So many viewers sent that.
Speaker 2: In to me. So we got a vaccine
done and we also got Regeneron and a lot
of other therapeutic things done which are
phenomenal and which and.
Speaker 1: Remember,
Trump didn't do any of those things.
Speaker 2: The, you know, people don't talk
about but really have been fantastic. The vaccine
was done in nine months instead of five years
or ten years or 12 years. And as you know, there
are many, many people that think that millions of
people worldwide have been saved because of that
for the vaccine. We'll see what happens. We're
going we're looking at it very, very closely.
But we got that done in nine months as opposed
to five years to 12 years. They said it was going
to take anywhere from 5 to 12 years if reelected.
Speaker 3: Mr. President, you would remove any
type of mandate at the federal level for our
military for first of all, for everybody when it
comes to this vaccine, because there are questions
about the side effects. So you would like.
Speaker 1: To know there are really no questions.
Speaker 2: The mandate. I didn't do the
mandate. Mandates were done by other people.
Speaker 3: Yep. Just want to
get you on the record for that.
Speaker 2: Under me?
Speaker 3: Yep. So many mandates.
Speaker 2: Were done by governors and they
were done by others. And the mandates were
very bad. I was against the mandates. I
was never for the mandates. And. All right.
Speaker 1: So, you know, he's trying to court an
audience on own that is not big on the vaccines.
That's the reality. And I don't know how
that's going to necessarily go over with
them. But Trump has very little. F then he
just doesn't even know where to go. Donald
Trump continuing the theme from his rallies of the
anti-trans stuff during this interview as well.
Speaker 3: This thing is exploded like it's okay
and normal to start cutting up a 13 or 14 year old
and use 140 different genders and two different
pronouns. This is nonsense. They're going after
our kids. Don't you think, Mr. President?
Speaker 2: It's true. And I ended that,
as you know, I ended it largely in the country,
but I ended it for our military. It was over. You
couldn't do it right. And there was a little bit
of fuss from a few people, but 99% of the people
agreed. This is a very this is an issue that if
you ever took a real poll, it probably would poll
at 1%. And they're trying to destroy our country.
Speaker 1: So this is now a theme. This is you
know, we started seeing this actually at
CPAC where the biggest applause lines were
the overtly homophobic and transphobic ones.
And we're increasingly seeing this and it's a
really depressing thing to see absent any
actual policy. Last clip here, Trumpers,
as well as Trump himself, want to paint a picture
of the Golden Age of America, the summer of COVID,
even though it was actually the summer of COVID.
Speaker 2: And we're not that far away. We had
something going so special two years
ago. We were leading the world in
every category. Every group within our
country was meeting African-American,
Asian, American, women, men, Hispanics.
Everybody was leading young people,
old people. We were all doing great. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Remember that? That was when hospitals
needed to bring in refrigerated trucks as morgues
because they were out of space for the people dead
from COVID in the hospitals. Another bizarre
interview completely disconnected from reality.